actually so what do you do well first
things first let's talk about 1% so when
you talk about percentages percent means
percent cent means like a hundred a
hundred cents in a dollar a hundred
years in a century you know a hundred
feet on a centipede right so percent
means per hundred so one percent we're
really talking about 1/100 now look at
1/100 see how this is like divided by
100 when we divide a number by 100 what
we do is we actually move the decimal
place two places to the left so for
example if we have a hundred and twenty
let's just use this as an example one
percent of 120 we would move that
decimal one two places so now if we're
talking about one percent we'd be at one
point two now say for example they
wanted you to find two percent of 120
well we know what one percent is two
percent is double right so we just have
to take one point two multiplied by two
and we've got two point four three
percent we just multiply it by three
there'd be three point six etc
say for example they asked us though for
10% now again remember percent / means /
so percent means 10 over 100 now if we
reduce this by dividing the numerator
and denominator by 10 that reduces to
1/10 1/10 means we're dividing by 10
when we divide by 10 we just take that
number we just move the decimal one
place to the left so 10 percent of 120
would just be 12
what would 20 percent of 120 be well if
10 percent is 12 20 percent would be
twice as much of you 24 if it was 30
percent every three times as much would
be 36 etc let's take a look at 33 and
1/3 percent 33 and 1/3 percent that's
1/3 right so 1/3 or something means
we're dividing it by 3 into three equal
parts so if we were to take 33 and 1/3
percent of 120 120 divided by 3 is 40
say for example we wanted 66 and 2/3
percent that's double 33 and 1/3 percent
so that's going to be double 40 that's
going to be equal to 80 right okay let's
talk about 25 percent now so 25 percent
is 25 over 100 right
twenty-five percent means per hundred
but if we reduce this we get one-fourth
which means like we're dividing by four
we're dividing into quarters just like
there's four quarters in a dollar right
that means it's a four so we're dividing
by four so 1/4 120 would be 30 now if
you wanted to find 75% that's 3 times
25% that's triple this we would triple
this would be 90 right 50% that's
probably the easiest one to understand
when somebody says 50% I mean they're
cutting it in half right so half of 120
would be equal to 60 okay so let's jump
into some more examples see if you can
do these ones on your own and you can
check them with this video here and see
if you're on the right track so 10% of
450 so we said 10% is really like
dividing by 10 we're moving that decimal
one place to the left so this one 45
right okay now one percent of 35 well 1%
we said was like dividing by a hundred
one part out of a hundred so we're gonna
move that decimal two places to the left
we're at 0.35 or you could write it as
0.35 ten percent of 750 same thing 10
percent we're just like dividing by 10
you move that decimal one place to the
left one percent of 400 we move it two
places to the left so that's going to be
4 3% of 600 a little bit more
challenging well let's find out what 1%
is we move that to places that's going
to be 6
that's one percent but we want three
times as much 3% that's gonna be three
times 6 which is 18 20 percent of 900
let's find 10 percent move that one
place to left that's 90 20 percent is
double so that's gonna be 180 25 percent
of 48 well we talked about 25 percent is
like 1/4 or dividing by 4 if we divide
this by 4 we get 12 7 percent of 500
well let's find out what 1 percent is
move that 2 places to the left that's 5
7 times 5 is 35
60% of 80 well let's find 10% of 80 10%
we move the decimal one place to the
left that's 8 60% is 6 times 10 percent
6 times E is 48
33 and 1/3 percent of 24 33 and 1/3
percent is 1/3 that's like dividing by 3
24 divided by 3 is 8 okay let's look at
letter K 70% of 40 let's find 10% that's
4 7 times 4 is 28 15 percent now this
one we can do a couple different ways 15
percent is really like 10 percent plus 5
percent let's find out what 10 percent
is 10 percent we move that one place to
the left that's going to be 2.8 now 5
percent is half of 10 percent right so
half of 2.8 is 1.4 if we add those
together you can see we're getting 4.2
okay so that's a good way to do it 10
percent cut the 10% and 1/2 add them
together 50 percent we talked about was
half so half of 90 is 45 75 percent
let's find out what 25 percent is that's
like dividing by 4 that's like 1/4 so
that's going to be 4 and 75 percent is 3
times 25% so 3 times 4 is 12
250% now this is a more challenging one
see 100 percent really means the whole
thing right if somebody says I'm gonna
give you 100 percent you know of my
sandwich that's the whole thing right
but 200 percent would be like 2 times as
much 250% 50 percents like half so we're
really talking about two and a half
times as much so let's do two times as
much 2 times 38 is 76 half of 38 is 19
if we add those together what do we get
5:1 we're looking at 95 okay so the last
one 66 and 2/3 percent we're talking
about 2/3 but let's talk about 1/3
that's 33 and 1/3 percent 1/3 when you
divide by 3 that's 1/3 so that's going
to be 9 66 and 2/3 is double 33 and 1/3
so if we multiply this by 2 you can see
we're getting 18 so that's the basic
idea if you understand this idea of one
percent moving the decimal one place to
the left I'm sorry two places to left 10
percent you're just moving at one place
to the left 33 and a third is dividing
by 3 25% is dividing by 4 50 percent is
dividing in half 66 and 2/3 is double 33
one third so figure out this first and
then double those are the key ones if
you understand those it'll be easy to
calculate these percentages mentally so
I hope that helped you understand how to
work with these better subscribe to the
channel leave a comment in the comments
below if you have any just further ideas
about how to do mental math as far as
percentages are concerned otherwise I
look forward to seeing the future videos
and I'll talk to you soon